here's what would happen if you didn't
sleep for a week
after just 24 hours you'd feel the
effects of your sleeplessness you
wouldn't be able to pay attention your
hand-eye coordination would get clumsy
and decision making would be challenging
to say the least after 36 hours prepare
for your cortisol insulin and human
growth hormones to be thrown out of
balance night two is where things get
tricky here you'd probably experience
micro sleeps when your brain would enter
involuntary sleep-like States waking up
from these would leave you confused and
disoriented 48 hours with no sleep would
disrupt your immune system leaving you
vulnerable to bacteria and viruses
somehow you'd make it through all 168
hours but it wouldn't be pretty have fun
hallucinating and experiencing Illusions
though because